alright we're going to go back into the
past can do yesteryear and talk about
things that happened the early 19th
century as I think I made it clear I
have great interests the question of the
difference between the old world the New
World and whether we are warranted in
writing modern history as if the old
world the new world or Europe and the
Americas were on a similar trajectory
even if of different rates or whether
there are fundamental differences but
that be you know that sort of the broad
perspective that I'm interested in I got
to talk about three specific topics that
come out of the French Revolution and
particularly out of the the Napoleonic
period following the French Revolution
the first of these is law the second one
is military the third one is religion
with respect to law it is pretty
straightforward you had for legal
scholars were employed by Napoleon to
write up a law code which was a code of
civil law later became known as the code
napoléon but that was not its original
name and it was a effort to put down in
EM comprehensive and logical form a code
of laws for fort for the state the code
Napoleone remains the basic shape of
french law down to the present day and
it becomes a pattern for the
legal systems of most of the rest of
Europe so this is a a type of
codification that really has only two
parallels that I can think of one of
them is the gist in Ian's code that goes
back to the Byzantine Empire and the in
the 6th century and the other one is the
the great tonk law code in China going
back to the 10th century uh where you
had efforts to simply think of movie you
know the legal system in its totality
this is not a product of the revolution
this is a product of the Napoleonic
period but it becomes possible because
of the disappearance of the of the
monarchy and therefore the disappearance
of the idea that you had a monarch a
sovereign who had essentially sovereign
capacity to to create law or to change
law Britain does not become subject to
this and so the law that you have in the
United States is descended from the
common law of Britain which is
dramatically different from the Code
Napoleon it's not a straightforward
civil code but rather a ongoing
cumulative tradition in which citing
decisions in earlier cases is the common
way of proceeding to to a decision and
to deciding how to rule on a new case as
opposed to simply going back to the to
the text of the of law code a common law
is the best parallel for common law is
the Islamic sharia
because they're what a jurist would do
or a judge would do would be to look at
the case at hand and then go back and
review all of the text would be
pertinent to that case from
authoritative sources like the Quran and
hadith but also look at how earlier
jurists had had ruled in these cases so
that you would have decisions that were
based on a very lengthy and scholarly
you know survey of all of the previous
decisions by important people on a given
on a given case and then the
jurisprudence come up with his own
conclusion as to what should be the case
here so then the the collected opinions
of important jurists would be published
and would become the references that
would be used so the the common law and
the Sharia are in one category where
you're dealing with precedent and you're
dealing with an expiration of how
similar cases were decided in earlier
times as opposed to the codified law of
the Code Napoleon where you have simply
the the text of the law the Islamic law
as it came to be applied in come in
North Africa is closer to the codified
law of the code Napoleone let's say
there's one school of Islamic law that
is specific to North Africa on the
Maliki school that that produced
handbooks like law codes and seemed to
give them more importance
than the than the survey of earlier
opinions that you had in the other
Muslim law schools I I'm kind of making
these comparisons because we often think
that legal legal traditions really don't
bear comparison across cultural
boundaries but in fact it's very useful
I think to to realize that the way juras
think is is very much that falls into
certain types of thinking Jewish law for
example would fall more into the case of
Sharia and common law then in the case
of codified law there's no Jewish law
code but there are several thousand
years of opinions that prominent people
have taken them when you have an issue
you go back a new survey of the Talmud
and the response of the collections of
opinions of medieval and early modern
rabbis in order to find out what the
text of the law now how it should be
applied in the current in the case of
hand so this was a major consequence or
major after effect of the French
Revolution that is not in any way Adam
graded in the revolution itself in other
words the revolution was not you know
led us overthrow the king so that we can
have a law code because it's something
that comes after and could not have come
about had it not been for the revolution
but it was not a purpose of the
revolution changes in the military are
similarly not inherent in the revolution
and yet they were very significant
changes of the primary one being the the
creation of mass citizen armies by the
French Revolution so when you go back to
the 18th century before the Revolution
and you look at the way of the way wars
were fought and there were many many
wars they were typically fought by a
fairly small armies that is to say there
are major battles and something like the
Seven Years War the French and Indian
War I was we call in the United States
where you might have had twenty or
thirty thousand men in the army and that
would be a very big battle the total
size of the military available in
various countries was normally well
under five hundred thousand men at arms
and then there's a question of how was
that army constituted and it be
constituted in in two ways you did not
in general have conscription though here
and there it did occur you did have
essentially kidnapping and putting
people on a boat and saying you're now
in the Navy or mustering them into the
Army in other words you were continually
sweeping up vagrants and adventurous
young men and putting them in in uniform
but the total number of say in France
prior to the revolution the number of
volunteers for the army most occasions
when you can count them would say under
20,000 year I think 18,000 was largest
number of volunteers I run across so
that you simply didn't have huge armies
the people in the army we increasingly
were focused on the infantry and yet
there's no major change in technology at
this point in time cannon are becoming
more useful for field artillery
operations as opposed to sieges but
basically people stood in line and shot
at one another the rate of fire for a
gun was about not the most three shots
in a minute because you had to reload
you had to reload through the muzzle and
if you had three shots per minute that's
your highest rate of fire that does not
allow any time for aiming there's not
much evidence that people aimed they
shot they reloaded they shot they
reloaded and the amount of killing that
was achieved was not sufficient to
really stop in advancing infantry in
other words when you see these pictures
of the line of soldiers marching against
not a stationary line of soldiers and
you say well why are these people
continuing to march forward when they're
being shot at well they weren't being
hit for the most part in the movies you
know the guy in your left is he up the
idea right is hip you know everybody's
being hip but actually not so much the
level of casualties for a battle in the
18th century would not commonly go much
over ten percent of the MV engaged
forces and having a fusillade of musket
fire was not sufficient to stop the
advancing infantry and so the battles
usually ended up in hand-to-hand combat
since so many of the soldiers were
pressed into service in national armies
as opposed to being volunteers their
situation was one in which they had to
shoot at the enemy because if they ran
away they would be killed by their
officers and it's sometimes conjectured
that the main battlefield use of light
cavalry in the 18th century was to shoot
the deserters to chase them down and
kill them in order to instill in every
soldier a greater fear of his own
officers and of the enemy know when you
say well the enemy isn't trying very
hard to kill me so maybe I'll just go
and fight the battle because if I turn
around and run away no sergeant
so-and-so is certainly going to cut my
head off I mean that's the soldiers were
caught in the peculiarly unpleasant
situation and of course it's been
conjectured the reason they use brightly
colored uniforms was in order to make it
difficult for them to hide if they ran
away so they can be easily tracked down
and identified by by their officers in
some places you had states that earned
money by renting out armies as the
Hessian the state of HESA did in the
Revolutionary War in America where the
Hessians fought his mercenaries most big
Wars had mercenaries fighting on one or
the other side because it was cheaper to
hire an army for a war than it was to
maintain an army on a regular basis on
this question of how do you pay for a
war is a very important issue not you
know throughout well now to the present
day basically the the French Revolution
did change this
France was invaded by monarca coal
neighbors uh from more than one side and
France proceeded to create conscription
in which they they built an army of
about a million and a half men which is
like three times the size of any
preceding French army and it becomes
pretty much the first Army to be
actively propagandized as a
ideologically motivated fighting force
unlike mercenaries who fought for pay or
like people who fought to avoid being
killed by their own officers the French
soldiery under the revolution fought for
France this was this is unusual now you
had had national armies before and that
saw themselves as as national in the
sense of representing the king the
largest armies in Europe prior to the
French Revolution largest arm is
probably the Swedish army under high
point of the Wars of Dunder gustavus
adolphus and the swedish army included
about six percent of the male population
over the total population in the army
that's a very high percentage the 19th
century you do have times when the when
the army will reach five or six percent
and that represents a huge huge number
of people say by our standards now that
would be in having 15 million people in
the army six percent of 300 million in
this country
or five percent so so you started to
have battles or being fought on a much
larger scale and the French armies were
consistently larger than their enemies
and this caused your enemies to start to
change to having larger armies when you
have larger armies they began to change
the role of the officers because larger
armies required the movement of military
forces around the battlefield and
preparing for the battle and the
coordination of their travel and
logistics in a way that the smaller
armies of the eighteenth century had a
little bit less important so officers in
the 18th century prior to the revolution
were normally in most parts of Europe
from the aristocratic portion of society
officer ships were for sale so that if
you were from the right noble background
you could you could start your own
regiment you had to pay for it you had
to find soldiers who are willing to
fight in it or press them into service
but there was very little expectation
that the officer had any particular
military skill maybe he was trained to
you know sword fight or something but he
was not trained as an officer so that
what you have in the under Napoleon
after the French Revolution aftermath is
the building up of military academies
for training officers and yet when you
look at officers and the and you start
getting bourgeois officers and but even
then recruiting good officers is
difficult there's one record of a a
general who commented that of
the the 30 captains who'd been sent to
him as officers for his forces only
three of them were literate so the
bourgeois background of the officers was
one of the big changes of the French
Revolution primarily in the infantry
most of the cavalry officers remained
Nobles under Napoleon despite the anti
aristocratic tenor of the French
Revolution so battles became larger
armies became larger officers became
more professional the cost of the
military became even more onerous and
you had conscription now as a mode of
enlisting people in the army and you
could motivate them by by ideology for
some countries the the question of how
long you served was a crucial issue so
that the prussians in particular adopted
a practice since they were limited in
the Napoleonic era and how many people
they could have in the army they adopted
the practice of conscription to serve
for two years and then have them be in
the reserve a trained reserved for
another seven or eight years something
like that so the notion that your army
was both your active force and your
reserves becomes a standard part of the
military change at that time after 1815
Napoleon is defeated the size of the
armies goes down radically you don't
have another big war in Europe until
eighteen seventy
franco-prussian war our austro-prussian
war just before it so what happened is
that the the bourgeois officers are
pushed out of the army and the noblemen
come back in as the primary officer
corps only now they are more likely to
be trained and this was sort of
reversing what the French Revolution had
visualized with respect to the
aristocracy but it it represents the the
sense of the part of the aristocracy
that the military is their particular
area of of expertise and under the
military academies they get more
training although many of the arrow
scraps still are not highly trained when
you look at the other side of the
Atlantic you don't find any of this the
keyword in the time of the of the
American Revolution and before was
militia militia were volunteers
initially at least who would serve for
the duration of a conflict but would not
become a standing army would not think
of themselves as the army of the of the
Republic did not train in the sort of
line of combat style of the European
armies and the armies were we're
comparatively small you did have a
military academy build at West Point
which was primarily for training
engineers there was little use for a
professional military officer
and after the by the time you get to the
presidency of Thomas Jefferson you have
a very substantial debate in America
over what to do about the Pirates
so-called who were there Corsairs who
sailed out of Morocco and Algeria and
Tunisia Libya and would capture merchant
vessels and enslave the enslave the
sailors onboard the vessel and steal the
cargo so these were called the Barbary
pirates and the issue with the Barbary
pirates was do you pay ransom in order
to get your ship back and your sailors
back or do you go to war and this became
a big debate in the United States the
the bane merchants were New Englanders
the southern colonies being much more
agricultural and so most of the ships
that were being seized by the Barbary
pirates were from Boston or Providence
or other places in New England and the
New England merchants came to regard
paying ransom as part of the it's like
insurance part of the cost of doing
business you know we ensure the ship and
indeed maybe you ensure the ship against
piratical seizure so you know if the
Pirates take the ship your insurance
like yo policy would pay for the ship
but but the New Englanders did not want
there to be a war
they didn't want there to be a war for
for several reasons one of them was that
they thought a war would cost a lot of
money and as merchants they did not want
to be taxed to you know pay for a war
secondly a war was likely to disrupt the
trade that they found profitable but
thirdly and seemingly the more important
issue was that if they offer if they
authorized the federal government to
wage a war against the Barbary pirates
then the government would have an army
and they did not want the federal
government to have a military force said
you know first Jefferson will get a Navy
and if he gets a Navy then he's you know
find some way to get an army because he
is basically a tyrant who wants to
militarize the United States because
there was really no no standing army to
speak of in the United States at that
time the Jeffersonians felt that paying
tribute to you know strange Muslim
potentates in Libya was a disgrace and a
scandal and that we had to go to war to
you know to free these slaves and to
suppress piracy there's a great deal of
publicity given to the idea of Americans
being made slaves New Englanders
countered and said you know if you want
to free slaves you don't have to go to
Libya or Algeria to free slaves you can
just go out you know out back and free
your own slaves then of the
Jeffersonians did not see the logic of
that and you had a very lively national
debate over the issue of is white
slavery bad and black slavery okay and
you had works written saying that well
Muslims
treat their slaves nice by comparison
with the way let us say Caribbean
planters or southern planters treat
their slaves and some of the earliest
stirrings of the abolitionist movement
the United States go back to this to
this debate over whether the US should
go to war to free white citizens from
slavery while maintaining a very large
black population in slavery Jefferson
won the argument we had a war the early
1800s against the Barbary pirates
preserved in the marine hymn that talks
about the shores of Tripoli which is
where the battles were fought we did end
up with a standing Navy the war
generated a dramatic poem about the
glories of America fighting the war by
francis scott key and then a bit later
in the war of 1812 when suddenly the
british invasion required that we
constitute a national army and a
National Navy Keary wrote the poem to
talk about you know oh say can you see
by the dawn's early light to to become
the national anthem but if you look at
the original poem that he wrote about
the Barbary pirates it's in the same
desire meter as the national anthem he
he was like to write poems about that
kind of thing I guess me in any case
when we think of the military history
United States we often overlook the fact
that the colonies have individual
militias just as we have national guards
in each state now and that they were
very very suspicious of there being a
national army
so unlike the Napoleonic era in in
Europe which produced bigger armies
bigger battles national ideologically
stimulated armies in the United States
you still have the notion that a citizen
militia was the way to go down until the
Civil War when all those things that had
become expected of warfare in Europe
came home to the to the United States
and you had massive conscription huge
armies huge battles and with the
improvement weapons greater percentage
of of casualties so the North American
military and the European military go in
somewhat different directions South
American military is convulsed in the
early 1800s by a whole series of
revolutionary movements that have fairly
small armies but are bent on creating
independent states so this is when you
get independent state starting
particularly in the northern part of
South America and the exceptional case
of Brazil where the King of Portugal who
is displaced by the Napoleonic invasion
relocates to Brazil and becomes declares
Brazil an empire and becomes Emperor
Brazil which is initially predicated on
the assumption that he will return to
Portugal when times get better but over
time he becomes much more Brazilian in
his outlook and you have a Brazilian
monarchy or Empire down until just about
the end of the 19th century
um so things on the European side of the
Atlantic moved militarily in a somewhat
different fashion than those on the
other side of the Atlantic just as they
do in the area of law there's the third
thing I want to talk about i think is
more important of at least from my
perspective than the other two and that
is the question of of religion
the conclusion of our chapter that my
colleague wrote talks about how Western
society how was on its way but not yet
complete after this era and as I
mentioned last time the thing that he
left out of his sort of list of criteria
for a mature Western society was
secularism religion on in Europe and
religion in America go in very different
directions following the French
Revolution and the Napoleonic period we
don't tend to write about it very much
because the history religion is first of
all it's rather arcane and secondly it
seems to be something that in the can we
master narrative of the risible
guarantee religion seems to be something
that is destined to fade away for the
last say 30 or 40 years is become
increasingly evident that religion is
not fading away and this presents a
problem of can we have a broad narrative
of last 300 years say it that is
passively accepting the notion that
religion is obsolete in after the
Enlightenment and is going to become
less and less important what do we do
with that narrative when the facts on
the ground appear to run in the other
direction and show that religion
regaining a very substantial political
social moral role in society's
subscribing to a number of different
faiths so somehow it seems to me we have
to explain where our contemporary
religious trends come from what why why
are things the way they are now hardcore
modern historians portray a revival of
religion as a sort of backward-looking
medievalist atomistic fanaticism that
inexplicably attracts people and that
probably is best explained as the
outlook of people who are opposed to
modernity are unable to understand lo
guarantee in other words you explain the
return of religion strictly and negative
terms sort of why do they hate us they
hate us because of our freedoms which is
not something they're saying but rather
something about we're simply French
revolutionary
he is standing army conscription and so
many religious ideas and then we also
grow in Egypt things are they're
actually heading in the opposite
direction that they're really more like
yes we are managed na you get don't have
ee ya know that there the question of
the comment deals with whether in the
Islamic world things are going more in
the European direction after the French
Revolution of the pulley on your period
and yes they are clearly the Middle East
and Europe are of a piece as they have
been for thousands of years I mean that
this is an artificial distinction
between the Muslim world and the others
but please actually fall into a later
chapter in the book so I'm not going to
go into details about that now I want to
focus really on the comparison between
what you get in on this side of the
Atlantic versus what you get in in
Europe the
the American Revolution is preceded by a
period of religious ferment called the
Great Awakening it is followed in
roughly starting roughly around the
1820s by a second great awakening so the
revolution is sandwiched between two
very powerful religious movements these
religious movements are very similar to
one another and they are highly
populists the first Great Awakening is
George Whitefield and Jonathan Edwards
are the primary preachers whitefield is
an Englishman he comes to America to
take over the the the ministry that in
Savannah Georgia that had been under
John Wesley the founder of the methodist
church whitefield and john wesley and
Wesley's whether Charles were all part
of a club at the holy club so-called at
Oxford and they were religious zealots
the hallmark of their of their ministry
was open air preaching what in later
times would become revival meetings
where you would get great throngs of
people coming to hear
these preachers whitefield in particular
was said to have had audiences of ten to
20,000 people listening to hit to some
of his sermons he was a short cross eyed
man but apparently had a powerful
powerful voice he was a friend of
Benjamin Franklin who at one point
actually measured the he was listening
to a preach and he walked until he found
that he could no longer distinguish what
the sermon was and then he calculated
the area that of people who could hear
it and he divided up divided by 2 square
feet per person and said well there
could have been 20,000 people there who
actually heard him speak and you know
whitefield traveled around he came to
the United States seven times gave
thousands and thousands of servants and
like Jonathan Edwards in New England his
sermons were extremely emotional so that
the idea that people would would feel
the Holy Spirit and get up and
hallelujah you know mm you know and
share in the in the experience this is
what became characteristic of the Great
Awakening and of the subsequent revival
movements in the United States so that
this notion of a charisma that would be
the you know the distinctive
characteristic of a particular creature
becomes built into this aspect of
American religion the Methodists and the
Baptist churches starting around 1800 a
little bit later grow phenomenally so
that if you look at the growth rates for
the Baptist's of the Methodists and
compare them say with the Episcopalians
or the Congregationalists or the
Catholics you have a explosive growth
for Baptists and Methodists and Lee and
they are the the groups that are
participating in these revivalists
movements and they are mostly in western
parts of the of the United States or
rural parts the United States there is
clearly a very populous character to
this but it's a type of populism that we
are that we are familiar with now in the
sense that the the doctrines that were
being enunciated maintained that you
to be saved that it was never hopeless
it wasn't the most hardcore Calvinist
view that would hold that you were
predestined to heaven or hell on the day
of your birth but rather you could gain
through your faith and through your
trust in God of the at least the
appearance of living a perfect life and
you could be redeemed from sim you know
Wesley believe that then you could atone
but that everybody was was susceptible
to temptation that you had to fight
continually against temptation to lead
this this perfect life the notion of
taking Jesus or God as your personal
guide and daily affairs becomes a part
of this
the idea that you should monitor the
behavior of your neighbors and try and
improve it by telling them what bad
Christians they are for drinking or you
know doing other bad things becomes a
part of it basically almost most of the
things that you find in evangelical
Protestantism today are present in the
18th century but even more around
between the 1820s and 1840s and the
Second Great Awakening there is in the
Second Great Awakening there is the
growth of new churches the there is a
man named Miller who predicted that the
world was coming to an end his followers
were Miller rights when the world did
not come to an end in the early 19th
century the event known by his followers
as the great disappointment some of his
followers maintained that the world had
in fact come to an end and that now we
were in the stage of the last judgment
but God had to work through the you know
the lives of each human to determine
whether they should be saved or or
damned and that was a big job it would
take him many many many years to finish
the Last Judgment Last Judgment was not
you know just sort of snap your fingers
and it's all done but rather God had to
review everything as God is just and
therefore you had the doctor in that
last judgment began and is continuing
and therefore you should act in an
extremely observant fashion and this is
the seventh day adventist
sect that arose at that time but that's
only one of several sex the Mormons
begin at this time the shakers in other
words it's a period of religious revival
but also of religious ferment in which
you have new sects coming into being
that they're only serve a marginal
relationship even to the Methodists in
the Baptist's but even more to the
conventional Church of England
Presbyterian Congregationalist a
background that you that you had from
from England why this Great Awakening
took place it's been debated some people
feel that there are precursor events in
what we called holy fairs in Scotland in
the 18th century where people would get
together and be holy together although
some of the descriptions of the fairs
make them sound a little unholy but by
and large this seems to be an American
more in American phenomenon than
something that has a direct relationship
to to what was going on at the same time
in England so in a sense religion
appears to be almost inseparable from
the from the mental outlook or the moral
outlook of the people who live through
the American Revolution on the other
hand the state that they created was a
secular state
secular in the sense that it would not
support any particular religion and
would prevent all religions to to
operate the assumption presumably being
that everyone would have a religion even
today of course when you poll Americans
about what they would think of having an
atheist for president the negative
opinion on an atheist president has been
massive and unchanging for decades you
know we gradually accept a woman
president or a I imagine people at even
accept a Muslim president before an
atheist president because you know it's
just wrong to be an atheist in the
popular mind so that typically you'll
have you know in America people say well
you know you should in this moment of
crisis you should go and pray in the
church or synagogue of your choice yeah
well what about not praying is that an
option can we say now in response to
this terrible tragedy you should pray in
the church or synagogue your choice or
or not whatever you like no the idea of
freedom of religion was that you were
free to be religious of whatever
description religion you had a mind but
you what you shouldn't feel free to be
non-religious well what is what is
strange here is that to me is that this
you get a disjunction that grows between
a national ideology of separation of the
government from an established religion
and the mentality of of the people who
become intensely or continue to be
intensely religious
quite a number of years ago I was
pursuing research on what names parents
give to their sons I had a theory that
said that if you looked in a
quantitative few large quantitative
bodies of names that you would find
suggestive patterns in the names of
parents came to their son this was based
through the sons is based upon two
assumptions the first assumption was
that naming an infant is more or less
the only act of free will you ever have
the infant can't fight you and young
it's your call this isn't true in all
societies some societies will have
limits so you have to have a name that's
the name of a Catholic saint or
something like that but in American
society you can name your son George or
Keyshawn or you know Billy whatever you
want it's up to you so so you have free
will which killings are very
uncomfortable with in general and
therefore that takes them nine months to
figure out how to solve that dilemma you
know it's much harder to name a child
than it is to buy a car where you have
certain choices certain parameters and
so on the other assumption is that when
that one of the factors that enter into
the decision chain that parents go
through is will this name be good for my
son i'm using sons here because
daughters are kind of a different
situation your daughters are not
necessarily particularly in prior to the
20th century not necessarily assume to
be people who are going to live a public
life
they will marry they love children their
status will be determined more by their
spouse than by their own their own
achievements you know a typical L sexist
sort of situation so but with sons I
have thought that parents will name some
sons after famous people or after an
uncle who died or having the same
initial as the uncle who died or
something like that but at some point
they will take into account or many of
them will take into account whether a
name is good for their son whether it's
going to serve his his interest let's
say that the number of boys named Adolf
in this country plummeted after say 1933
or so and still has not come back I have
never met any boy in this country
citizen America who's named Adolf
there's a reason for that yeah you think
gee now I grow up and I hate all you you
don't want that the same reason you
don't find many boys named Lily but but
if you if you take that those two
assumptions then you say if I aggregate
large numbers of male names and divide
them by date of birth I can see kind of
a profile the social psychology of the
parents not of the children themselves
for the parents so to test that theory
it was a theory i was interested in
because i had done similar work in
turkey and subsequently I've done
similar work about naming of sons in
Iran but I was interested in seeing
whether theories that I was applying to
the Muslim world would work just as well
for
you know for my own culture so I decided
what's the easiest source of a large
number of names that extends over a very
long period of time in the United States
and that is easily accessible and that I
can coerce a TA into tabulating for me
phone book doesn't give you a date of
birth problem is you need a date of
birth and you also have to go back
before there were telephones so there
are some things that weren't very easy
well the easiest thing it turned out to
be in my view was the Alumni lists of
Harvard University simply because they
go on for so long from 1636 the
University opens and because they are up
until the 1950s almost exclusively
people from Massachusetts it was only
after World War Two that Harvard began
to democratize in the sense in its
notion of taking in people from other
parts of the country and from public
high schools so I started tabulating or
getting my my biniam to tabulate these
thousands of names and came up with a
interesting graph you know several
different types of graph the public the
one now is a graph where here is a time
axis
there's a percentage axis what he was
interested in is how many what
percentage of the of the Harvard
students have names from the Old
Testament names from the Bible and
leaving aside the name John simply
because it is so until really the 1990s
it was the most popular name in every
age cohort throughout American history
so leaving aside John then what was the
status of biblical names it turned out
that you start around 1600 with about
forty percent thirty-five to forty
percent biblical names and then it goes
up pink SAT around forty five percent so
the most popular names are Benjamin
Samuel Daniel you know but you also get
the Ebenezer's and the Zechariah's and
no so forth and so on oddly enough David
is not particularly common although it's
an Old Testament name but you get these
very very you know absolutely
incontrovertible names from the Bible
then you have an inflection point goes
up to forty five percent and then heads
down in a curve that is almost almost
smooth i was using no three year running
averages and so I smooth about somewhat
and the biblical names disappear so by
the time you get to the bottom of the
curve you find that eight percent of
these Harvard lads have were given
biblical names of the time of their
birth so the question was what is the
inflection point when does when does the
Bible disappear
or begin to disappear from the mental
equipment of parents as they are
thinking about the lives of their sons
and for all intents and purposes in 1776
with the creation of the United States
the Republic people in Massachusetts
began to think that maybe a biblical
name is less pertinent than a
non-biblical name and they continue to
think that way until the biblical names
virtually disappeared so that you got no
more Benjamin's no more Daniels people
associated the remaining biblical names
sometimes with backward rural areas so
someone is called Zeke I think oh that's
deliverance for you I mean now someone
named Zeke is obviously a hick or
Ebenezer I mean but but the fact of the
matter is that this was a very clear
trend so what you have is that as and
this state here approximately eighteen
fifty so throughout the Second Great
Awakening you're having a passion for
religion and a diminution of biblical
naming and this is puzzling except that
it suggests that the division of church
and state may play a role here that
people as citizens are getting citizen
names and yet they are expected
personally to be people of a religious
conviction
relaxing oh yeah no no I ok the question
of regional and sectoral stratification
I I wanted to have a highly homogeneous
body because then if there was a single
trend it would stand out instead of
having overlapping trends that would be
harder to then I'd have to work with
subcategories of the population it's
hard to do however no one even then well
maybe even more so then was a Harvard
graduate at birth so the fact that their
Harvard graduates spoke to the social
and economic capacity of their parents
but not to their own personal
accomplishment because they got their
name before anybody knew who they were
so yes it is the you know the bourgeois
class of Massachusetts that's
represented here on the other hand that
is very likely be the class that was
most sensitive to the issue of
citizenship to the sorts of questions
that were bound up in the Barbary Wars
about what is the role of the government
and so forth now if you look at what
names people were given who were not
being given biblical names what do
people shift to
saints names no there are no Catholics
in this crowd uh nope nope nope nope
nope they're the first names of the
English kings george william edward
richard not that Richard so much but
they are the most mundane english first
names they are not from the Bible nor
are they Saints names well George's is
is really tricky because the found the
first president was named George and our
opponent was named George in the
Revolutionary War so so George is kind
of a wash you could be a Tory and name
your son George or you could be a
patriot named their son George and
nobody would know so George does become
one of the one of the do names but then
you get down here and you're stuck at
eight percent you're stuck at eight
percent then the curve goes up starting
in the 1950s and there are 22 thoughts
that I've had on that one is the that is
when Harvard diversified for example
when the Irish are moving into boston
and the Italians are moving into Boston
you don't see Patrick and Michael and
Luigi showing up on the Harvard alumni
list because they're not bringing these
immigrant groups into Harvard but by the
time you'll get to the 1950s when
Harvard and the post-war era is else as
with Columbia or Princeton or other you
know self-proclaimed elite institutions
they're trying to diversify that is when
you you begin to see the return religion
but then when you but by that time you
also have global statistics for the
United States as a whole and you can see
that yes this is when religious naming
begins to appear
and you get you know Jonathan instead of
John oddly enough in the in this later
period when you find mostly our new
testament names so Luke and Mark Matthew
these become important names here and
they don't exist at all here Paul so
there's something very new testament
about the the revival of religion in
this country from the 1950s on and at
this point my sample becomes much more
chaotic because i can't i don't have the
assurance i had earlier that i was
dealing with a fairly homogeneous social
group I've I what I was doing this I
thought that quantitative onomastics was
the wave of the future for studying
social psychology from a historical
point of view and then nobody would
publish my article in the subject so I
decided it was not the wave of the
future and so I've sat on this for you
know 30 years but I'm still intrigued by
him because I think it does suggest that
there was a fundamental change in mental
outlook that came along with the
American Revolution and that it was in
the one in one sense it was secular it
was secular but insofar as it is
simultaneously with very powerful
religious currents it seems to me that
it represents more this notion of a
separation of citizenry from from
religion rather than the disappearance
of religion from Massachusetts life
he is Massachusetts escena of the
evangelical saurian still Presbyterian
Church well Jonathan Edwards was a
Massachusetts preacher in the first
Great Awakening and but it's true that
you have more of the Congregationalist
and Unitarian and piss capelean sects in
Massachusetts and probably even more in
the in the you know roster of Harvard
graduates than you would have had at
large and it's possible I haven't I have
no way of I don't have any date on it
it's possible that people were we're
going to secular names in order to
distinguish themselves from the zealots
in the Second Great Awakening saying
we're not one of those Methodists or
Baptists who you know continue to name
their son Zeke but rather we are it's
they're much more English it's now the
interesting thing is that as the as the
curb of presidential name names comes up
or not presidential but of names of the
Kings then it goes down you get another
rising curve which is not defined by my
particular names you have clusters of
names that come and go but is defined by
the variety of naming and in statistics
or something called an index of
dispersion where you say that if you
have oh say a hundred people and they're
all of the same name then there's no
dispersal it's zero if you have a
hundred people and a hundred different
names then it's it's one it's between
the index between zero and one and you
have total total dispersal the reason
you look at this is to see whether when
you have a growing variety of names
whether in fact people are still
focusing just on
a handful of the most popular ones but
what you find is that from a low point
right in here is actually a little bit
earlier than this 1850 from a low point
there in where you a very little variety
of naming you have an explosion in the
in the number of names given to these
Massachusetts citizens and in the
variety of the names i did a parallel
study of graduates who in oxford college
and you have almost notice verse this
version they in England at the similar
social level they're only you know a
dozen or so names and most people had
three or four of them you know John
Richard Edwards you know Throckmorton or
something because they had multiple
first names but but in America you had a
amazing spread of names and one of the
most you look at it why'd you get so
many names and one of the things that
happens is that virtually every last
name becomes a first name so if you had
say in Massachusetts the Cabot's and the
lolz and the Henley the lodges then
you'll have someone who don't at one
point you at Ebenezer Lowell and then
maybe John Cabot but then by eighteen
fifty or so you're going to get Cabot
Lowell and local Lodge and lodge Cabot
Lowell so forth all these names have
become first names and it's it's the
creation of a national identity that
people become this time and people
become obsessed by their genealogies and
they turn they don't go back they don't
have a mother country to go back to but
they start turning their last names in
the first names
so you know how else would we get a
Confederate President named Jefferson
Davis Jefferson is obviously a last name
so there are very complicated things
going on in the social psychology at
this time but it is strikingly different
from the social psychology that you get
in England and continental Europe with
respect to religion on Napoleon in 1801
has an agreement with Pope Pius the 7th
in what's called the Concordat that the
agreement states that the majority of
the people in France are Catholics but
it does not make Catholicism the
religion of France it says you can be
French and be of some other religion but
now recognizing that the majority of the
people are Catholics it recognizes the
power of the Pope to remove a bishop
from office but the bishops are
nominated by the French government the
bishop that the Pope cannot put his own
man into a bishopric religious figures
priests and self and so forth are paid a
salary from the state so long as they
swear allegiance to the state you get
different variants of this in other
parts of of Europe in the Napoleonic
post-polio time but the idea that every
religious figure who holds a position in
a in a church or synagogue or whatever
receives a salary from the state becomes
commonplace in Europe where in the
United States is anathema you know we
cannot have the federal government
paying a salary to film too
the Archbishop of New York City that's
just wrong but in Europe that's the norm
you you have other situations where for
example you have the law passed
requiring that we that every child say
in the Belgian law every child is
required to be instructed in religion in
the public schools in the religion of
his or her faith so that the public
schools had to teach Catholicism to the
Catholic students Protestantism to the
Protestant students Judaism to the
Jewish students if you were an atheist
in modern interpretation you were
allowed to be excused from religion
classes and then of course you got the
issue of will the state pay a salary to
a Muslim to teach Islam in the public
schools and of course that was required
by the Belgian Constitution there was
resistance to that idea until the Saudi
government said we will pay the salary
of the Imams who teach Islam in your
public schools but of course then
they're going to be taught Saudi Islam
and this ended up getting the chief of
the Saudi educational mission to Belgium
assassinated because there are parents I
don't think they were found the assassin
I'm sure it's a parent who said I'll be
damned if I have my kid taught by a
Saudi no ma'am but the thing is control
of religion became the norm you know the
French Revolution tried to abolish
religion Madden work the controller
religion becomes the norm in Europe in
the Middle East whereas a less a faire
attitude toward religion a company by an
expectation that every citizen will be a
religious person becomes the norm in the
United States and in this sense America
part company from Europe so that
let's say European numbers for belief in
a divine being are on a percentage basis
very very small in America is sixty
percent which is extraordinary because
most of the correlation is worldwide
study that's been done is that the the
lower the per capita income the stronger
the belief in God and that as your per
capita income goes up according to what
we think of modernization people become
less and less religious and that works
pretty well for Europe although some of
the least religious countries in the
world are the post-soviet Baltics who
are just totally fed up with the whole
thing but there are some outliers that
is to say some countries that are in the
highest category for four per capita
income are Saudi Arabia and the Gulf
shakedowns when they also have ninety
percent belief in God but aside from
from the oil States the only country in
the world that has a really high per
capita income and a really high belief
in God is the United States and you know
this is going to turn out to be to be
historically consequential and when we
look at at people who assume if they're
writing about Europe that Europe is
post-christian you cannot assume that
the United States is post-christian and
therefore the notion that you have a
Western society that is characterized by
secularism you have a Western society
that is characterized by particular
relations with religion but there there
are two different flavors you know once
peppermint the the Europeans want to
control religion and they don't believe
Americans want to have a less a faire
attitude to our religion and they want
and expect people to be believers so we
don't have a Western civilization that
ends up on the same page in this respect
and i would say that to some degree that
applies also to the military and to the
legal outlook that what happens in in
the americas particularly in north
america although there are parallels
that we'll get into in another chapter
in other parts of the new world is
really profoundly different from what is
happening in the old world that's it